The last plot that we'll make for this course is called
a Heat Map. For our data set we want to display
each combination of gene and sample case, the difference in gene
expression and the sample from the base line. We want to display combinations
where a gene is over expressed in red. in combinations where
it is under expressed in blue. Here's the code to make that
Heat Map. First, we'll run all of this in order to
melt our data to a long format. And then we just run
our ggplot code using the geom, geom tile. Now,
this last line is going to give us a scale gradient.
And we're going to use the colors from blue to red.
So, let's see what the output looks like. And, there's
our Heat Map. Even with such a dense display, we
aren't looking at all the data. In particular, we're just
showing the first 200 genes. That's 200 genes of over
6,000 of them. And since this data set was produced.
Genomic data sets of these kind, sometimes called
micro data are only getting larger, and more complex.
What's most interesting, is that other data sets also
look like this. For example, internet companies run lots
of randomized experiments. Where in the simplest versions, users
are randomly assigned to a treatment like a new
version of a website or some sort of new
feature or product or a control condition. Then the
difference in outcome between the treatment and control can
be computed for a number of metrics of interest.
In many situations, there might have been hundreds or
thousands of experiments and hundreds of metrics. This data
looks very similar to the genomic data in some
ways. And this is why the useful maxim plot
all the data might not always apply to a
data set as it did to most of this course.